في اثناء قالت هيئه الاركان الاوكرانيه ان
قواتها الجويه نثذت في الساعات الماضيه
نحو 20 غاره على نقاط تمركز القوات
الروسيه في مناطق عده واسقط ثلاث مروحيات
وثلاثه مسيرات روسيه واضافت ان القوات
الروسيه تنفذت خلال اليوم الماضي اكثر من
ثلاثين غاره جويه وصاروخيه على مواقع
اوكرانيه لم تسميها
في مقاطعه
قالت وزاره دفاع الروسيه ان قواتها نفذت
ضربه انتقاميه ضد القوات الاوكرانيه في
مدينه
كرماتورسكا بمقاطعه دميه ليله راس السنه
الوزاره قالت ان الهجوم
او ان الضربه ادت الى مقتل 600 عسكريا
اوكراني في هذه المدينه
معنى من موسكو مراسله الجزيره رانيا دريدي
ومنكياف مراسل الجزيره تامر حسني
ولا ربما يكون الحدث الابرز ميدانيا الذي
اعلنت عنه القوات المواليه لروسيا وهو
السيطره على
بلده او مدينه بخمس كويت القريبه من
سوليدر ما هي المعلومات المتوفره حول هذه
السيطره وحول هذه المدينه بالتحديد
نعم حسن يعني ما بلده بخموس هي بلده يعني
يمكن القول انها متخمه تقع على اطراف
مدينه سوليدار سلدار التي تشهد معارك
داميه خلال الايام الماضيه في محاوله من
قبل القوات المسلحه الروسيه للسيطره عليها
السيطره على مدينه بخموس التي تقع على
تخوم هذه المدينه هذا يعني حسن ان القوات
المسلحه الروسيه باتت تحاصر مدينه سلدار
وتسيطر على المدن والبلدات التي تحيط بها
فضلا عن ذلك هنا اود التذكير بان همم وفقا
للمصادر العسكريه الروسيه كانت القوات
الروسيه قد خرقت امس خطي الدفاع الاول
والثاني في مدينه ساردار وكانت تحاول حسب
المعطيات الاخيره اختراق خط الدفاع الثاني
هناك الثالث هناك همم معارك عنيفه دائره
في وسط مدينه لدار نفسها وفي المناطق
الجنوبيه من الاداره وعليه فان
الاعلان اليوم عن السيطره على هذه البلده
هذا يعني حسن ان هناك تقدم كبير من قوه من
قبل القوات المسلحه الروسيه لاسيما وان
الحديث يدور عن تكبد القوات المسلحه
الاوكرانيه لخسائر كبيره في هذه المدينه
هناك همم هناك تصريحات تفيد بان القوات
المسلحه الاوكرانيه لاسيهما قوات اللواء
128 باتت تغادر مواقع
هناك تقدم على الاقل وفقا لكل هذه
المعطيات تقدم من قبل القوات المسلحه
الروسيه في هذا همم في هذه المدينه فضلا
عن ذلك همم يعني همم بلده
الطريق على محور بخموت يعني هناك الطريق
الذي يؤدي الى منطقه مدينه التي تشهد ايضا
معارك داميه بين قوات القوات المسلحه
الروسيه
والقوات المسلحه الاوكرانيه وعليه فان
السيطره على هذه البلده يفتح الطريق هذا
القوات المسلحه الروسيه لاتمام همم واحكام
محاصره القوات المسلحه الرئيسيه في مدينه
باك من فضلا عن ذلك يفتح ايضا همم الطريق
امام القوات المسلحه الروسيه للتقدم نحو
الشمال لاسيما نحو مدينه مدينه مدينتي
سلاماتوس التي
اعلنت وزاره الدفاع الروسيه امس شهدت
القوات المسلحه الاوكرانيه فيها ضربات من
قبل القوات المسلحه الروسيه السفره عن
مقتل اكثر من 600 عسكري اوكرانيا في خطوه
انتقاميه من قبل القوات المسلحه الروسيه
ردا على استهداف القوات الروسيه في مدينه
السلام من
تدريدي حول السيطره على بخمه سكوير بما
يؤكد هذا الكلام ما حقيقه ما ينقل عن وضع
الجيش الاوكراني في هذه المواقع
في الفعل مريم من رئيس الاوكراني لا ينفي
صعوبه الاوضاع ككل داخل مدينه سلدار
والحديث ايضا عند محمود ولكنه اكد بشكل
واضح بان المدينه ما زالت بالكامل بالكامل
تحت سيطره القوات الاوكرانيه والحديث ايضا
عن باخمود قال رغم الدمار الكبير الذي
الحقه القصف الروسي المتواصل بسونيدار
وبخمود فان القوات الاوكرانيه ما زالت
تمسك
المدينه
وانقل عنه حرفيا قال بان في كل منطقه في
كل شارع في كل زاويه يتم ال- ال- ال- همم
القتال بين القوات يجري القتال بين القوات
الاوكرانيه والروسيه فان هنالك قتلى من
القوات الروسيه وجرحها ايضا لكنه بالفعل
اقر بصعوبه الاوضاع وهذا ما اشار اليه او
اشار اليه في الحقيقه يوم امس نائبه وزير
الدفاع الاوكرانيا التي قالت بان الاوضاع
صعبه غايه وبان القوات الروسيه تكثف من
هجومها على سوليدار وقالت بان الجانب
الروسي سيعمل كل ما بوسعه من اجل الحصول
على اي شيء باتجاه سليدار من اجل الدعايه
من اجل الترويج الدعائي كما وصفته واظهار
بان اظهار ان القوات الروسيه هنالك تحقق
نصرا لكن ارجع واقول بان القوات
الاوكرانيه حتى هذه هي اللحظه الرئاسه
الاوكرانيه حتى هذه اللحظه تقول بان
سيليدار في قبضه القوات الاوكرانيه
وباخموطه ايضا القتال همم يعني يشهد تطورا
كبيرا خلال الساعات الماضيه على جبهه
دونيتك وعلى جبهه لوغانس والرئاسه
الاوكرانيه ايضا تحدثت عن مدينه ثالثه وهي
خيرسون وقال بان الرئيس الاوكراني بان خير
سون تتعرض للقصف متواصل
بالذخائر الحارقه بالقليل ايضا تحدثت
الاداره العسكريه في خرسان عن ذلك واشارت
الى ان المدينه منذ الليله الماضيه وحتى
هذه اللحظه تتعرض لقصف متواصل الاحياء
السكنيه البنيه التحتيه المدنيه لقصف
متواصل بالمدفعيه وبراجمات الصواريخ
وبقدائف الهاون وتحدث القائد العسكري
الاوكراني هناك عن اكثر من 70 هجوما خلال
الساعات الماضيه تعرضت له المدينه لكنه
ايضا تحدث عن استمرار القتال بالمدفعيه
الثقيله بين القوات الاوكرانيه والروسيه
على طول ضفتين هاردينيبر تجدر الاشاره الى
انه قبل قليل ايضا مستشار الرئيس
الاوكراني نشر على صفحته في التلجرام
مقطعا مصورا لقصف روسي وقع قبل قليل صباح
هذا اليوم على مدينه خارقه ايضا شرق
البلاد
شكرا جزيلا لكم